bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre en direct
les questions cribles thématiques
consacrés au financement du transport
collectif en france le transport
collectif c'est un sujet très important
pour de nombreux élus locaux notamment
depuis que l'écotaxe a été
définitivement enterré et bien lancé
comme un certain nombre de transports
collectifs sont en danger des centaines
de lignes de bus de tramway certains
métros dans l'hexagone tout de suite eh
bien on va prendre la direction de
l'hémicycle et bien c'est le sénateur
ump philippe dallier qui a la parole mon
passion de la taxe sur les bureaux
visant particulièrement les parkings des
entreprises et une augmentation de la
taxe spéciale d'équipement certes la
région ile de france peut s'en féliciter
mais la ngp certainement pas car dans
ces conditions se demande si elle
disposera des moyens nécessaires par
ailleurs même avec ses 140 millions
supplémentaires nous ne savons pas non
plus tenant compte de la baisse des
dotations de l'état aux collectivités
territoriales si la région ile de france
pourra financer la totalité des projets
de modernisation et d'extension du
réseau existant beaucoup de projets sont
à l'étude
c'est le cas dans mon département seine
saint denis les études avancent les
enquêtes publiques avancent on intéresse
la population et les visuels au causse
avec des projets de transports dont on
ne sait pas si on vous du compte ils
seront financés voilà pourquoi il me
semble important de sionistes de
clarifier cette situation et ma question
est simple quand aurons nous enfin un
plan de financement précis permettant de
réaliser à la fois le projet du grand
paris express et ceux inscrits au plan
de modernisation et d'extension du
réseau francilien bien pour répondre à
la parole et à monsieur alain vidalies
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
oui merci à monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur vous avez raison
d'aborder ce dossier qui est un dossier
majeur puisqu'il porte sur pratiquement
32 milliards d'euros sur la totalité de
sa réalisation c'est un projet qui doit
mobiliser me semble-t-il de l'ensemble
des forces concernées est un projet
certes pour la région parisienne mais
c'est un projet d'ampleur nationale vous
le savez ce projet il ya quelques
chiffres qui sont révélateurs de son
ambition 200 kilomètres de lignes de
métro supplémentaires 70
gares et c'est un projet qui a largement
fait consensus dans ses objectifs il y
avait toujours et c'est bien normal des
questions qui étaient évoquées sur son
financement et sur les rendez vous que
l'état avait donné notamment lors de
après les décisions qui avaient été
annoncés je le rappel par le premier
ministre lors du comité interministériel
sur le grand paris le 13 octobre dernier
le premier ministre a confirmé
l'attribution de 2 milliards à la
société du grand paris pour le plan de
mobilisation que nous évoquons et le
premier ministre dès ce moment là a
indiqué que les premières conventions de
financement serait signé dès la fin de
cette année en particulier pour
l'extension des halls à l'ouest et le
prolongement de la ligne 11 du métro à
l'est la participation de l'état au
volet mobilité de ce futur contrat de
plan état région prévoit vous l'avez
rappelé pour l'île de france un budget
de 1,4 milliard d'euros pour financer
ses opérations sur la période 2015 2020
et vous le savez également et vous
l'avez rappelé c'est ici que nous tenons
nos engagements on vient de voter les
140 millions de recettes pour la région
ile de france affectés justement à ce
financement il y avait des doutes cette
le vote a été est intervenu aujourd'hui
il y a un plan de financement des
recettes et des conventions qui seront
signées pour la réalisation d'un grand
projet monsieur d'heuliez en quelques
secondes monsieur le ministre sont les
chiffres que vous avez cités nous sommes
d'accord mais nous ne sommes pas
convaincus ici que tout cela suffira à
financer à la fois le grand paris
express et le plan de modernisation de
la région c'est bien là la difficulté et
les projets se multiplient alors avec la
région avec les départements de la
région ile de france mais nous ne savons
pas si au bout du compte nous trouverons
les crédits suffisants et je regrette qu
effectivement il n'y ait pas un grand
rendez vous qui rassemble l'état à la
sgp et la région et quand on puisse
enfin nous démontrer pas seulement
jusqu'à 2020 mais au bout de ces bouts
de ce processus qui nous emmènera
probablement jusqu'en 2025 je
souhaiterais qu'on nous démontre
effectivement que les crédits sont là
parce que si c'est pour dans quelques
temps encore nous demander de revoter
des taxes qui pèseront sur les
entreprises de la région ile de france
et c'est sur les particuliers parce que
ce sont eux qui financent aujourd'hui eh
bien je pense que ça n'est pas la
meilleure solution merci monsieur délier
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue yvon collin merci aux du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
mesure 2 minutes maximum merci monsieur
le président monsieur mise mais chaque
collègue l'abandon ni plus ni moins de
l'écotaxe poids lourds sans avoir
préalablement mis en oeuvre
l'expérimentation prévue constitue
monsieur le ministre un très mauvais
signal envoyé aux usagers qui attendent
avec impatience la modernisation de
l'offre et l'amélioration de la qualité
transports collectifs certes pour
l'année prochaine le manque à gagner
pour la chance de financement des
infrastructures de transport lafitte
sera compensée par le renforcement de la
fiscalité sur le désert auprès des
particuliers des transporteurs routiers
ce qui doit permettre une stabilisation
de son budget par rapport à celui de
2014 ce budget à hauteur de 9 de 1,9
milliard d'euros voire un peu plus du
fait de l'évolution des autres tâches
affectées restent insuffisants pour
garantir la réalisation des projets
d'infrastructure retenu suite au rapport
du député philippe durand projet
indispensable pour le désenclavement
dans le territoire dont le montant
s'élève au minimum à 30 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2030 cette solution
nécessairement provisoire ainsi que la
suppression par l'assemblée nationale
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
finance du versement de transport
interstitielle instaurée par le sénat
dans le cadre de la récente réforme
ferroviaire soulève de réelles
inquiétudes sur le financement des
transports collectifs alors que les
dotations des collectivités
territoriales continuent de baisser dans
ces conditions monsieur ministre face
aux multiples incertitudes qui entourent
désormais ce dossier est au bras mesure
de nous préciser comment le gouvernement
va-t-il financer les indemnités dues à
la société ecomouv pour la résiliation
du contrat est de plus comment l'on fit
pouvoir financer lafitte pour assurer
l'engagement pris par l'état en matière
d'infrastructures de transport je
remercie dieu ministre en charge des
transports pour répondre à monsieur
colin merci mc président monsieur le
sénateur jeu sur la question du contrat
et comme j'en reviens pas sur les
conditions de sa suspension puis de la
résiliation du contrat même si je nous
invite je vous invite collectivement à
réfléchir sur les raisons qui ont amené
à l'impossibilité de mettre en place ce
qui avait été imaginé à l'époque
aujourd'hui il y a deux objectifs la
premier essai
comment financer la fuite et vous l'avez
rappelé cette agence qui permet de
financer des infrastructures et qui pour
l'année 2015 devait bénéficier d'un
milliard 900 millions à consacrer aux
infrastructures
je vous précise l'engagement de l'état
est clair lafitte bénéficiera pour 2015
pour 2016 pour 2010 est de la somme d'un
milliard 900 millions qui est sécurisé
et sécurisé comment d'abord faut-il
rappeler parce qu'on le dit pas assez
que la fuite bénéficient d'autres
recettes que celles qui étaient attendus
et notamment des recettes qui
proviennent de qui sont payés par les
autoroutes il ya une partie des recettes
qui viennent la taxe d'aménagement du
territoire c'est quand même plus de 500
millions de redevances domaniales dont
je rappelle que ce gouvernement-là
augmenté de 50% la redevance domaniale
et payées par les sociétés d'autoroute
c'est aujourd'hui 310 millions dans le
budget pour 2015 des amendes sur les
radars payé par dont un parent après les
radars de 130 millions et de l'aide et
donc nous avons ces recettes qui son
père elle et nous avons donc puisqu'il
n'y avait plus la recette qui était
attendu augmenté de 2 centimes le gasoil
sur les véhicules légers et de 4
centimes sur les véhicules les poids
lourds ce qui fait d'un côté de plus de
800 millions de l'autre côté un peu plus
de 300 millions et donc nous avons un
budget qui est un budget sécurisé et je
crois que c'est l'important on peut
toujours se dire qu'il aurait pu être
sécurisé un plus haut niveau mais je
rappelle que les 1 milliard 900 millions
c'était l'objectif avant que se pose la
question de la résiliation du contrat
donc cet objectif il est aujourd'hui
remplie par d'autres moyens mais il y
aura bien ces financements là pendant
trois ans pour les infrastructures
scolaires mon cher collègue oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci de votre réponse monsieur
le ministre est néanmoins je suis pas
complètement rassuré j'aurais aimé que
vous puissiez que vous puissiez en
particulier me donner quelques garanties
sur la poursuite du projet lgv toulouse
bordeaux qui peut-être paraît
relativement assez en tout cas sera sans
doute retardé j'aurais aimé d'un mode
répond de monsieur le ministre comment
le précisions merci merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue ronan dantec
pour le groupe écolo ville avait la
parole mon cher collègue
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues face à une
fracture territoriale qui s'aggrave
doter l'ensemble des territoires de
moyens de transport collectif efficace
accessible et respectueux de
l'environnement est un enjeu majeur le
financement des offres et
infrastructures transport et donc une
question cruciale est malheureusement et
ça fait écho à la question précédente et
signaux donnés par l'état n'ont pas ces
derniers mois témoignez d'un engagement
clair de sa part je rappelle en
particulier la suppression de la taxe
sur les poids lourds on vient d'en
parler mais la part collectivités
territoriales qui devait affecter n'est
elle pas sécurisé ou encore de la hausse
de tva sur les transports collectifs
le tout dans un contexte de baisse des
dotations de l'état aux collectivités et
de difficile bouclage les contrats de
plan état région faute de moyens
financiers
dans ce contexte renforcer les capacités
d'intervention financière autonome des
régions dans le domaine du transport
collectif est une urgence et une
nécessité c'est donc avec surprise et
incompréhension que nous avons appris
que dans le projet de loi de finances le
gouvernement vient de supprimer le
versement transport interstitielle
régional qui avait été créée dans la loi
de réforme fermière par un amendement au
sénat a adopté par une large majorité
transcendant les clivages partisans
versement transport est un prélèvement
obligatoires sur les entreprises
rim en donnée pour justifier cette
suppression est que ce gouvernement ne
veut pas taxer plus des entreprises
c'est un peu court monsieur le ministre
et c'est oublier un peu vite que la
qualité des infrastructures et des
services de transforce r la
compétitivité de nos entreprises c'est
un atout france est reconnue réduire les
flux financiers d'investissement c'est
affaiblir notre pays et renforcer le
sentiment d'injustice dans un certain
nombre de territoires qui se vivent déjà
en relégation ma question est donc
simple alors que les régions sont
chargés demain dans le cas du schéma
régional de l'intermodalité de
coordonner les politiques conduites en
matière de mobilité par les autorités
organisatrices de leur territoire et
qu'elles vont prendre de nouvelles
responsabilités dans leur cadre de la
loi notre quels outils financiers
nouveaux imaginez-vous pour financer les
politiques régionales transport
versement transport régional
interstitielle ou additionnels aux de la
part régionale de haïti si peu ph poids
lourds régionaliser les propositions ne
manquent pas le gouvernement doit
aujourd'hui préciser sa position pour
vous répondre la parole et a reçu alain
vidalis vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le monsieur le
président monsieur dantec pardonnez-moi
10 secondes dire à monsieur collègues se
désole de ne pas avoir répondu à une
question qui m'avait pas été posée donc
c'était difficile d'imaginer qu'il
fallait comprendre aussi que vous
parliez de l'autoroute toulouse
bordeaux
sur la sur la question du versement
interstitielle puisque vous aborder ce
problème
le texte qui avait été voté pour être
très précis il avait un objectif il
partait d'un raisonnement qui consistait
à dire le versement transport c'est
quelque chose extrêmement important pour
aujourd'hui dans notre pays c'est 7000
plus de 7 milliards au total à peu près
la moitié pour la région ile-de-france
le reste pour la france c'est essentiel
et donc la démarche qui est fait lorsque
le débat et d'amendements ont lieu au
sénat c'est de dire il ya pour les
régions aujourd'hui des zones où les
entreprises notamment les entreprises de
plus de neuf salariés ne paie pas parce
qu'elles ne sont pas comprises dans un
périmètre de transport urbain c'est ça
le raisonnement et on se dit je vous
renvoie au débat ça va rapporter à peu
près une évaluation 400 millions qui
pour l'ensemble pour l'ensemble des
régions il ya d'abord un problème
technique a en réalité
il se trouve que tel que rédigé tels que
la loi a été rédigée on s'est aperçus
après coup que en fait elle ne visait
pas l'objectif puisque quand on relit le
texte actuel en droit positif s'il
n'avait pas été supprimés ce texte ne
visait que les villes de plus de 10
mille habitants en dehors d'un périmètre
de transport urbain c'est à dire que le
rendement attendu de fait tomber autour
de 75 à 80 millions de dons de toute
façon il fallait y revenir mais ce qu'a
dit le gouvernement lorsque a été
présenté l'amendement qui supprime à ce
stade complètement le texte n'est pas
que le débat est clos
c'est que naturellement ce débat est
ailier vous l'avez fait vous même à la
question des compétences lorsque vous
allez avoir un texte sur les compétences
des régions il paraît assez cohérent et
vous nous le rappeler lorsqu'on ne l'est
pas et vous avez raison de discuter à un
moment donné à la fois des compétences
et des moyens d'exercer ses compétences
c'est le seul message que le
gouvernement a voulu faire en rectifiant
d'une part une erreur et renvoyant sur
lui à là où il doit se dérouler merci
monsieur dantec pour répliquer aux
ministres oui merci monsieur milices
pour votre réponse qui a le mérite de
nous donner une perspective donc si je
vous entends bien n'avait pas une
position de principe contre ce versement
transport interstitielle simplement vous
voulez qu'on se laisse quelques semaines
pour en rediscuter présentait donc des
amendements dans le cadre de la loi
nôtre j'entends votre proposition de
travail donc j'espère que vous ferez
propositions pour qu'on se retrouve
autour d'une table et qu'on améliore le
dispositif je crois quand même que
derrière cette question mais vous
n'aviez pas le temps de répondre à
l'ensemble va se poser quand même demain
la question de l'autonomie des recettes
financières des régions par rapport à
leurs nouvelles incompétence sur les
transports infrastructures et transports
collectifs donc je crois
qu'effectivement il faut absolument
aujourd'hui que nous donnions des
signaux clairs sur quelles seront demain
les recettes autonome des régions parce
que si on a plus de compétences ou
toilettage de compétences nous ne
réglons pas c'est un vieux tabou
français la question de l'autonomie
fiscale des régions mais je vois que
vous restez ouvert nous vous ferons des
propositions dans le cadre de la loi
notre merci mon cher collègue la parole
est maintenant notre collègue evelyne
didier pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen merci président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
depuis 2004 et je et rebondir sur la
question de du collègue précédent depuis
2004 la région sont devenus autorités
organisatrices de transport elles n'ont
pas reçu à ce titre de juste
compensation financière alors même
qu'elles ont fortement développé l'offre
la réforme territoriale en cours de
discussion renforce cette compétence
sans que pour que des moyens nouveaux
soit identifiée alors monsieur le
ministre vous évoquez la question de du
débat est en tout cas je ne vois pas
pour l'instant de moyens attribués le
tout dans un environnement fne
financiers peu propice aux
investissements nouveaux et égard à la
réduction des dotations de
fonctionnement parallèlement le
gouvernement semble s'orienter davantage
vers le transport routier nous avons eu
quelques annonces notamment par voie du
bus jugé plus compétitives par un
raisonnement économique qui nous
semblent tronquée et à courte vue
tronquée parce qu'on ne se pose pas la
question de la sécurité ni celle de
l'environnement à courte vue car à terme
le réseau routier lui aussi devra être
rénové et cela demandera beaucoup
d'argent si l'on en juge par l'état du
réseau qui s'est dégradé depuis quelques
années les infrastructures constitue
l'un des points forts de notre pays l'un
de nos atouts compétitifs pour employer
votre vocabulaire ne pas garantir des
financements adéquats c'est perdre cet
atout ou apporter de mauvaises réponses
par la privatisation des réseaux et le
choix de la route au détriment du train
nous avions nous proposer en 2012 une
attitude plutôt offensive instauration
d'un livret d'epargne pour financer les
transports la généralisation de la taxe
poids lourds parce que nous étions pour
la nationalisation des autoroutes la
participation renforcée des entreprises
justement par le versement transport
vous tourner le dos à ces questions et
si on encore très récemment comme en
témoigne la position du gouvernement sur
le versement alors je viens d'entendre
monsieur le ministre vous nous disiez
que effectivement la porte n'était pas
fermée je m'en réjouis et nous verrons
donc dans le débat pouvez-vous en tout
cas me donner des compléments d'en faire
mention sur ce sujet sachant que je vous
pose vous avez deux fois la même
question bien pour vous répondre la
parole monsieur a la vida liste veda
parole du must merci à monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice
en complément des éléments que j'ai déjà
donné et plus particulièrement pour
répondre à votre question puisque vous
évoquez les initiatives que vous
contestez qui vont venir dans la loi sur
la compétition et éviter sur le
développement du transport par par
autocar je vais être très clair il ne
s'agit pas et la loi mettra les verrous
est nécessaire d'organiser ou de prendre
le risque d'une mise en concurrence avec
les lignes qui sont aujourd'hui
organisée par les régions et notamment
avec les lignes ter ça n'a strictement
rien à voir l'objectif est de constater
aujourd'hui qui se développe qu'on le
veuille ou pas en france et qui se
développe en europe surtout un modèle
qui est un modèle sur des longues
distances ou sur des trajets à
l'intérieur d'un pays mais au dessus de
200 250 km du transport qui est du
transport par autocar on peut faire tous
les discours qu'on voudra c'est un peu
le même débat que celui que l'on a eus
lorsqu'on a regardé l'arrivée l'arrivée
du voyage aérien low cost en disant ça
c'est pas pour nous sauf que ça
correspond aussi à un moment donné aux
besoins des gens et quand parce qu'il ya
cette réponse là des gens qui ne peuvent
pas parce que telle est la situation
sociale ont accès à ces moyens de
transports alors que je pense que c'est
pas réactionnaires c'est même assez
progressistes de leur dire que vous
aussi vous pouvez vous pouvez voyager
dans tous les cas la france je pense
nantis de ce qu'a été le retard pris sur
l'aérien doit regarder ce développement
du transport par autocar avec lucidité
et puis avec l'idée qu'il y avait là
aussi des gisements d'emplois en prenant
des précautions nous en sommes bien
d'accord il s'agit pas d'organiser la
concurrence avec le rail il s'agit
aujourd'hui de mettre en oeuvre des
possibilités simplement déclaratif
puisque aujourd'hui en france il faut
beaucoup d'autorisations pour pouvoir le
faire de manière à ce qu'on soit ce
rendez vous donc je voulais vraiment
vous donner ces précisions par rapport à
votre question qui était légitime sa
collègue pour répondre au ministre oui
merci monsieur le ministre effectivement
je prends note de tout ce que vous venez
nous dire et qui est très intéressant ce
que je me permets tout toi de faire
remarquer c'est que nous savons bien que
entre le rail et la route il n'y a pas
tout à fait égalité vêtements puisque
rappelez vous ce qu'ils transportent des
voyageurs ou du fret sur les lignes de
chemin de fer paye une location des
sillons à rff ce qui n'est absolument
pas le cas du transport routier que ce
soit les bus ou les camions et donc il y
à distorsion de concurrence nous ne
cessons de le rappeler d'autant que les
routes il faut pas l'oublier sont
entretenus par les collectivités et
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons qu'il y
ait un rééquilibrage dans ce domaine je
vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue jean jacques
filleul pour le groupe socialiste la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre la question du
financement des transports collectifs
intervient alors que de nombreuses
interrogations s'expriment à tous les
niveaux de responsabilité
commission européenne gouvernement les
différentes strates de collectivités
territoriales qui assument leur part de
transport collectif sur le territoire
national dans des conditions qui mérite
d'être vu souvent et qui pose question
de ce débat cet après-midi le transport
collectif est globalement financer plus
par l'impôt que par la contribution
personnelle des usagers dans le contexte
actuel c'est un sujet qui mérite
discussion un titre personnel je crois
en la nécessité d'un rééquilibrage
toutefois lorsque l'on dit cela se pose
alors tout
beaucoup de doute beaucoup d'autres
raisons de ne rien faire
l'objectif devient alors pour les élus
les a ôté et les exploitants des réseaux
de trouver de nouvelles sources de
financement afin de poursuivre le
développement de l'offre de transports
publics et de faciliter le report modal
les collectivités font face à des
dépenses croissantes dans ce domaine qui
n'ont pas été suivie d'une hausse
équivalente des recettes les usagers ne
supporte en moyenne qu'un cinquième des
coûts d'exploitation des réseaux de
transport en commun qu'ils utilisent je
n'ai pas l'intention en deux minutes de
couvrir l'ensemble de la problématique
simplement revenir moi aussi sur un
problème qui nous a beaucoup intéressé
au sénat
le versement transport
intertice yale il a été votée ici voté à
l'assemblée nationale
et malheureusement
refoulé si je puis dire lors du plf 2015
c'est pour nous évidemment un problème
parce que nous comptions sur les 4 100
et 400 brusque 450 millions qui était en
en filigrane de notre amendement
monsieur le ministre n'ayant plus mon
temps pour les régions et je précise je
ne suis pas conseiller régional comment
comptez vous aider les régions dans
leurs compétences ter alors que ce
versement interstitielle n'existera pas
pour vous répondre la parole est comme
suit à la vie d'alice vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre mais merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur je pense que j'ai
déjà largement évoqué la question sur le
versement interstitielle simplement vous
avez fait une observation qui est
logique et qui doit imprégner notre
débat et qui pose des questions
politiques extrêmement extrêmement lourd
c'est vrai que nous arrivons aujourd'hui
en france a un système où on résumer à
quelques centièmes près le financement
du transport c'est 70% le contribuable
et 30 % l'usagé ce chiffre n'a pas été
toujours celui là puisque il y à pas mal
de temps c'était plutôt 50 50 et que on
arrive progressivement à cette situation
et il faut aussi que nos compatriotes
comprennent que nous avons en france
système avec des prix de transport qui
sont extrêmement bas et si quelqu'un
avait un doute je vous invite à aller
prendre un ticket individuel de métro à
paris à londres et vous verrez ce que
c'est la différence et le oui c'est à
peu près le double voilà à peu près le
double exactement et si monsieur
karoutchi je vois que vous avez à
l'heure de vous interroger si en plus
vous n'êtes pas convaincus vous prenez
le train et vous aurez la confirmation
donc il y à un choix mais derrière c'est
pas que simplement une question de
financement vous comprenez bien c'est
aussi une question de choix de société
sont des gens qui vont travailler sont
des gens qui ont besoin de se déplacer
des gens qui ont besoin de mobilité la
mobilité doit pas être punitive à partir
du moment où justement on veut que les
gens utilisent transports collectifs
alors je pense que la question est tout
à fait légitime et juste il doit y avoir
probablement un réajustement mais il
sait l'europe être la seule réponse
politique aujourd'hui la réponse du
gouvernement n'est pas de dire bien
dorénavant on va faire payer l'usagé
d'une manière beaucoup plus importante
parce que socialement c'est pas possible
mais il y a là un constat une marge de
manoeuvre et je crois que parmi les
sujets importants que nous abordons
aujourd'hui ensemble vous avez eu
parfaitement raison de poser ainsi le
problème parce que je crois que nos
réflexions à venir nous devons être
marquée de ce constat notre collègue
jean jacques filleul pour répliquer au
ministre monsieur le ministre je ne
doutais pas de votre lucidité devant ces
problématiques importantes
on vous avait apporté évidemment tout ce
que vous pensez dans dans ce domaine je
crois qu'il faudra travailler sur ces
problèmes de financement du transport
collectif c'est important avec le
versement transport nous avions pensé
trouver une solution sans doute un petit
peu rapide mais en même temps bon le le
débat est lancé et ce après midi nous
permet de l'aborder dans de bonnes
conditions merci merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue jean françois
longeot pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants union
centriste il avait la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la question
du financement des transports collectifs
et naturellement essentielle pour les
représentants des territoires que nous
sommes car parler financement du
transport collectif c'est parler
financement des infrastructures qui
doivent permettre leur développement or
la situation actuelle de notre pays sur
les infrastructures de transport est
doublement préoccupante d'une part c'est
une problématique qui touche directement
l'aménagement du territoire comme nous
le rappelions mardi lors du débat sur
l'hyper ruralité l'état se désengage de
plus en plus des territoires éloignés
des centres urbains et des métropoles
notamment sur l'aspect de transport
comme pour le numérique investir dans
ses infrastructures c'est investir dans
l'avenir c'est améliorer la vie
quotidienne des français et se remettre
un peu d'égalité entre les territoires
d'autre part situation est également
inquiétante car le gouvernement
abandonne jour après jour les éléments
de financement même si vous essayez de
nous démontrer qu'on r qui devrait
permettre ces investissements en
infrastructures en octobre c'est la
suspension pure et simple de l'écotaxe
eux qui devaient france financer la ftf
il y a quelques jours c'est la
suppression du versement transport
interstitielle qui avaient été
introduits dans la réforme ferroviaire
par le sénat tout ceci met un coup
d'arrêt au financement des routes de
nouvelles lignes ferroviaires et
d'accompagnement des ter ma question est
donc simple monsieur le ministre en
renonçant à toutes ses sources de
financement allez vous abandonner toute
idée d'investissement dans les
transports comment allez-vous participer
au désenclavement de certains de nos
territoires je vous remercie sur le
ministre pour répondre à jean françois
longeot merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur
j'ai indiqué que pour 2015 2016 2017 les
fonds de la fit c'est à dire l'agencé
qui finance ces infrastructures sont
garantis à hauteur de ce qui était
attendu c'est à dire un milliard virgule
neuf non pas avec les ressources qui
était celle prévue à l'origine mais avec
de nouvelles ressources et je vous
précise que si pour 2015 la ressources
provenant notamment pour les
transporteurs de l'augmentation des
quatre centimes a été retenu c'est parce
que nous avons évidemment apporter cette
réponse à l'urgence que nous avons mis
en place un groupe de travail avec les
associations de transporteurs j'étais ce
matin devant le congrès de la fntr sur
le principe est d'ailleurs il faut le
rendre au marché depuis le début ils ne
contestent pas le principe de la
nécessité de participer c'était sur les
modalités et donc nous sommes en train
de débattre c'est pas leurs propositions
une autre association pense à une
vignette qui aurait probablement
l'intérêt par rapport à l'eau système de
la taxe sur le gasoil de faire aussi
payer et non pas de faire que payer les
camions étrangers comme ça ça n'est pas
possible mais aussi de les faire payer
dans nous réfléchissons à ce système
dans tous les cas nous sommes d'accord à
partir du 1er janvier 2016 il durera
probablement un autre système mais les
montants entendre entendu sont
exactement les mêmes alors vous me dites
j'en doute bien coûter la la la le
conseil d'administration
de l' agence française pour le
financement des infrastructures a lieu
tout début décembre dans quelques jours
ils vont prendre acte qu'ils ont bien un
milliard 900 millions et ils vont
financer les infrastructures et j'ajoute
on le dit pas assez me semble-t-il tous
collectivement que cette agence est une
agence de financement mais que c'est
aussi une agence qui permet d'agir dans
le sens du report modal car si une
grande partie de ses ressources
proviennent de la route ces dépenses
sont principalement orientée vers le
financement notamment du rail mais aussi
des du fluvial et donc le rôle de cet
agent si les centrales on peut débattre
sur le volume en se disant elle pourrait
avoir plus de moyens dans tous les cas
je pense que cette agence on joue un
rôle très important vous y êtes total
tous très attachés et le gouvernement
aussi de la montre et en pérennisant ses
recettes jean françois longeot pour
répliquer aux ministres merci de merci
de votre réponse vous nous vous nous
expliquer qu effectivement vous allez
réfléchir à ce que ma les camions
étrangers puissent effectivement
participé mais je crois qu'on avait un
outil qui aurait pu fonctionner c'était
l'écotaxe et je pense que c'est dommage
elle n'est pas arrêté les simplement
suspendu donc il faudra peut-être bien
qu'il ait une décision qui soit pris sur
ce dossier bien selon non pas suspendre
les poursuivre et je vais donner la
parole à louis pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le ministre chers collègues le
modèle actuel atteint ses limites et
s'effondre sous nos yeux je parle du
financement des transports publics qui
n'est plus assurée en france je sonne
monsieur le ministre je sonne donc le
tocsin en espérant ne pas sonner le glas
bientôt quelques exemples de cette
situation très inquiétante
le ferroviaire le déficit de financement
est de l'ordre de deux milliards et demi
par an dont 1 milliard et demi de
déficit structurel
la dette cumulée de la nouvelle sncf
dépasse les 40 milliards et plus grave
va aller en progression ensuite vous
avez malgré des investissements majeurs
d infrastructures ferroviaires qui
continue le réseau continue de vieillir
et le fret et le fret qui devraient être
un fleuron d'une politique de transition
énergétique à son tour s'effondre
l'industrie ferroviaire elle-même la
troisième au monde mme annonce la
fermeture prochaine de sites industriels
alors que sur tous les bancs l'emploi
est une priorité des priorités le réseau
routier non concédé
lui aussi se dégrade dans le domaine du
transport urbain la progression rapide
des dépenses n'est plus compensée par
l'évolution des recettes tarifaires et
le vt atteint lui aussi ses limites
c'est le seul service public où le prix
en euros constants du service diminuent
d'une année sur l'autre là encore le
financement actuel est à bout de souffle
autre mauvaise nouvelle l'éco taxe
supprimée et monsieur le ministre vous
pose la question mais indemnité de
résiliation du contrat de l'ordre d'un
milliard n'est pas financière n'a
connaissance alors la situation est
grave aussi monsieur le ministre je vous
fais une proposition la réunion d'un
grenelle 3 pour associer l'ensemble des
acteurs pour trouver un financement
stable et pérenne de la mobilité je vous
propose quelques pistes
l'augmentation de la productivité du
système la lutte contre la fraude
l'ouverture à la concurrence monsieur le
ministre que proposez vous pour sauver
la mobilité de notre pays
monsieur le ministre
en charge des transports vevey la parole
merci monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
président du gart naturellement je
connais je connais votre
votre position et votre est votre
réponse au fond après avoir fait ce
bilan en important dans votre réponse
c'est l'ouverture à la concurrence la
libéralisation on sait très bien que
vous attendez des vies des miracles de
cette solution simplement les éléments
comparatifs montre que c'est
probablement un peu plus compliqué que
cela dans un certain nombre de pays vous
avez raison de le rappeler ce avait été
dit par un un collègue précédemment on a
quand même le problème
qui n'est pas un problème
tabou c'est celui de la répartition
entre le contribuable et l'usagé et qui
peut permettre d adaptation mais je
crois qu'il ya aussi la nécessité de
regarder ce qui ne fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui et comment on peut faire on
peut améliorer le système dans le
déficit courant de la sncf vous avez
aujourd'hui 300 millions qui proviennent
des tmt rien n'a été fait c'est un
système totalement hétéroclites comme on
en comprend rien quand on cherche trop à
trouver ce qu est la raison de ce
système il ya des trains de nuit à des
trains qui ressemble à des ter en a
d'autres qui ressemble à des tgv raté
enfin bref j'ai mis en place hier une
commission certain nombre de sénateurs
présents ici je salue ces fioles sont
membres de tous les goûts de tous les
groupes et des députés des experts s'est
donné six mois pour que ont redéfini ce
lin l'objectif c'est de maîtriser ses
dépenses là et d'avoir une réponse qui
correspondent à l'attenté des usagers
vous avez parlé du fret c'est pareil je
vais aller plus loin dans le détail nous
avons un énorme problème c'est la
question du fret capillaire c'est à dire
de ces lignes classé sept à neuf qui
sont aujourd'hui pas ouvertes voyageurs
ou utilisés par des industriels
dans la maintenance est totalement est
totalement obsolète et il faut que l'on
trouve une réponse et toutes les
réflexions sont possibles et je vais
engager et nous en débattrons lorsque
nous nous rencontrerons lors de la
conférence sur le fret nous débattrons
de ces questions donc aux pistes que
vous avez évoquées sauf c'est très
politique de la concurrence sur laquelle
je ne pense pas que ce soit la seule
réponse possible mais sur le reste elles
sont ouvertes effectivement il faut à la
fois maîtriser les coûts tu crois
peut-être trouver des ressources
supplémentaires et puis avoir une
clarification sur les compétences vous
avez raison mais ces chantiers ils sont
ouverts et le gouvernement très
concrètement les ouvre les uns après les
autres monsieur
monsieur le ministre gon d' vous avez
presque répondu presque quand je vous ai
parlé de l'indemnité de résiliation
effets de l'éco taxe là vous n'avez pas
cité
quand vous me parlez de l'ouverture à la
concurrence vous savez effectivement que
je crois simplement simplement que le
plus important c'est pâques le chat soit
noir ou blanc sait qu'il attrape les
souris et quand je passe la frontière et
que je vais en allemagne dans un pays
équivalent au nôtre
et bien qu est ce que je constate c'est
que l'ouverture à la concurrence jeudi
devant monsieur l'ouverture à la
concurrence c'est 20 % moins chers en
moyenne 1 uniquement 20% moins cher pour
le contribuable pour la collectivité et
donc c'est des services supplémentaires
pour les usagers donc ce n'est pas
politique c'est concret c'est pratique
c'est pragmatique et chaussées je sais
monsieur le ministre vous reste quelques
secondes quelques secondes alors le
chagrin que je dis ça
merci merci de bien vouloir bien si de
bien vouloir nos cieux le ministre
engagé aussi la lutte contre la fraude
et l'augmentation de la productivité qui
me paraissent être quelques pistes qui
sont là aussi transversale merci mon
cher collègue la parole est à d'autres
collègues françois aubé pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaite tout d'abord évoqué
la situation du nine que je connais bien
la ligne paris caen cherbourg
je pourrais en évoquer d'autres temps
notre territoire souffre d'un déficit
d'investissement
trains bondés conditions de voyage
déplorable incident technique à
répétition trains annulés tel est le
quotidien des usagers de la ligne paris
caen cherbourg
début 2011 la sncf dressé pourtant cette
ligne comme parmi les douze lignes dit
malade du réseau national dans la foulée
elle annoncé le lancement d'un plan
d'urgence pour améliorer la régularité
des horaires presque quatre ans plus
tard sur cette ligne fréquenté chaque
jour par 7000 personnes et qui fait
partie des délits n'est plus rentable du
réseau français on ne peut pas dire que
la vie des usagers des travailleurs et
beaucoup changé et ne se soit améliorée
les abonnés qui empruntent cette ligne
ont d'ailleurs entamé une grève
symbolique du titre de transport en
signe de protestation
monsieur monsieur le ministre personne
ne comprend alors où les grandes
métropoles mondiales choisissent
couvertures maritime que la normandie ne
voit ses perspectives de développement
freiné par un réseau ferré inadaptée et
vieillissant quand on pense qu'il y à 40
ans dans les années 70 e turbotrain nous
permettait de rejoindre la capitale en
1h20 contre 1h40 au mieux aujourd'hui au
départ de lisieux monsieur le ministre
je souhaiterais donc connaître
l'engagement du gouvernement sur
l'absolue nécessité et l'urgence de les
servir efficacement la normandie plus
précisément pouvait nous vous nous
répondre aux usagers de la ligne
intercités paris caen cherbourg j'en
viens justement à la ligne nouvelle
paris normandie dont le principal
objectif est de relier le grand paris à
sa façade maritime avec au lancement du
projet des temps de parcours annoncé
comme étant réduit à 45 minutes entre
paris et rouen 1h15 entre paris et caen
temps de parcours qu'ils ne sont
malheureusement plus d'actualité initié
en 2009 ce projet n'est déjà plus en
adéquation avec les promesses faites à
la basse normandie fin septembre dernier
la concertation sur le projet a pris une
nouvelle ampleur avec les coyotes et
territoriaux je voudrais donc savoir
monsieur ministre en deux mots quels
sont les engagements que le gouvernement
peut tenir pour améliorer la desserte
ferroviaire en normandie
monsieur le ministre
avec une attention particulière pour la
normandie
j-20 cris
j manquerait pas monsieur le président
je suis je suis très attentif
naturellement je pense que les la
question est légitime et notamment sur
l'état d'un certain nombre de trains
puisque ici cela rejoint ce que j'ai
évoquées concernant les l'été et et vous
le savez sur l'été et et
rff engagé demande de l'état un grand
plan de modernisation qui a été qui est
en cours de réalisation et qui visent
des lignes structurantes et notamment
celle ci est pour vous dire ma pensée je
pense que là le travail qui a été confié
à l'ats philippe duron et à la
commission va permettre d'apporter des
réponses extrêmement précises à 7 cette
situation parce que il nous appartient
de définir pour l'été et est ce que doit
être le thé au t2 l'avenir ce sera le
nom de la mission vous même de vendre et
aussi ceux qui l'année sur la ligne
nouvelle paris normandie dit
lnpn et notamment sur la question de son
financement vous le savez nous avions
engagé des débats est l'une des
questions qui étaient posées c'était la
participation la signature de la
convention avec la région ile de france
puisque la région ile-de-france une
certaine façon attendait que l'état
remplisse ses obligations par rapport à
la première question sur les 140
millions ceci est en fait aujourd'hui je
peux vous annoncer que le président
huchon soumettra la cour de la
convention d'étude à la délibération de
la première commission permanente du
mois de janvier ainsi nous serons
entièrement opérationnel pour passer aux
travaux pratiques sur la mise en oeuvre
de cette ligne suis ok
pour répondre au ministre président
monsieur ministère six de ses réponses
effectivement le souci majeur était
aussi l engagement de la région ile de
france vous rassurer sur le sujet malgré
tout et bien aux trains ne démarre plus
et donc il serait aussi urgent de faire
j'irai oeuvre de progression sur le
matériel et la ponctualité merci
monsieur ministre
la parole est maintenant à peu près
collègues odette herviaux pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole mes chers
collègues merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre ma question
concerne un sujet trop souvent à mon
goût délaissé celui des transports
collectifs entre le continent et n'osent
il
l'actualité troublée de mon département
le morbihan rappelle une nouvelle fois
les difficultés politiques
institutionnelles et culturel même de
notre pays assume est vraiment son
destin maritime nous savons défendre la
spécificité de la montagne de la
ruralité pas plus tard qu'hier encore
monsieur le président mais demeurons
trop souvent silencieux sur les atouts
et les contraintes de nos territoires
littoraux et insulaires comme s'ils se
réduisait à des espaces naturels
protégés aux touristes privilégiés et
bien non monsieur le ministre telle
n'est pas la réalité et elle n'est pas
notre ambition nous avons déjà échangé
sur ce sujet monsieur le ministre je
vous sais sensibles à nos préoccupations
car vous savez que nos concitoyens
insulaires n'ont pas la liberté du mode
de transport pourtant ces territoires
hausse de formidable potentiel de
croissance et de développement dans ce
contexte le parlement et le gouvernement
bien entendu doivent assumer leurs
responsabilités et se donner les moyens
de faire vivre les principes
républicains de continuité territoriale
et d'égalité d'accès aux services
publics à des tarifs raisonnables c'est
à dire normaux je souhaite donc que
cette question de la desserte des îles
métropolitaine fassent l'objet de
mesures de soutien forte rapide
notamment bien entendu dans le cadre du
prochain examen de la loi de l'autre les
régions devraient être identifiés comme
chef de file à condition de bénéficier
bien entendu d'un accompagnement
financier approprié je pense au cpr aux
fonds européens et c'est l'urgence de la
situation commande que nous agissions
vite monsieur le ministre nous îliens le
mérite bien
merci pour vous répondre monsieur le
ministre sur un civil
merci monsieur le président madame
madame la sénatrice vous m'interrogez
sur les conséquences de la décision
prise par le conseil général du morbihan
de réduire ou de renchérir parfois les
rotations pour la desserte passagers des
îles de groix belle-ile houat et hoëdic
c'est une question qui relève de la
compétence vous savez parfaitement
exclusivement du conseil général qui est
organisateur en la matière au sens de
l'article l 5400 31-1 du du code des
transports et donc lorsque vous m'avez
saisie ou lorsque des élus se sont
mobilisés à la suite des protestations
émises par les habitants
nous avons simplement dans le respect de
l'indépendance des collectivités
territoriales accepté de recevoir une
délégation a indiqué au préfet qu'il
devait essayer évidemment de faire un
travail pour demain de médiation car le
problème qui est posé je ne veux pas
aller au-delà de ce que je peux dire à
la place du conseil général du morbihan
il faut rappeler qu'il y avait eu des
observations de la cour régionale des
comptes et qu'elle est à l'origine de
cette décision mais je pense que au delà
il cette question et cette situation
elle pose un problème qui est le
problème effectivement de la situation
des insulaires et il y a de ce point de
vue des initiatives qui ont et qui ont
été prises des travaux qui ont été
entrepris notamment par le comité des
régions européennes
dès 2002 et je pense qu au delà de la
solidarité avec les habitants de la du
la mobilisation à laquelle vous avez
participé de ce que l'état essayent de
faire avec le avec le préfet des
réponses qui j'espère seront
satisfaisantes je pense qu'il nous faut
effectivement travailler y compris au
niveau européen pour traiter de cette
question car ces réponses là dans leur
rigidité ne paraissent pas répondre aux
particularismes de la situation de ceux
qui résident dans ces îles madame
herviou merci monsieur le président
monsieur midi je vous remercie pour
votre réponse mais je continue de penser
que l'avenir de nos il passe par des
évolutions institutionnelles à travers
une contractualisation région état
europe et la reconnaissance des
handicaps naturels liés à l'insularité
il est donc important qu'à ce titre les
régions concernées bénéficient d'un
droit à la différenciation et
l'expérimentation des solutions
nouvelles devront donc être imaginées en
effet monsieur le ministre à l'exemple
de l'île néerlandaise par exemple de tai
chi ling qui a mis en place un système
d'auto partage de voiture électrique
réduisant les coûts directs et induits
de la modalité temps sur le territoire
de l'île que entre l'île et le continent
dans l'intérêt de notre pays de nos
côtes de nos littoraux de nos îles nous
devons assumer nos atouts maritimes et
j'espère que nous serons monsieur le
ministre créatif mais aussi responsable
et surtout solidaire donc attentifs aux
îles du ponant madame le sénateur je
vais maintenant suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 16 heures précises pour
la suite de l'examen du projet de loi de
finances pour 2015
la séance est suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de questions
cribles consacrée au financement du
transport collectif en france pendant 45
minutes vous avez pu entendre le
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
alain vidalis répondre aux questions des
sénateurs alors certains élus se sont
notamment inquiétés de la suppression de
l'écotaxe yvon collin par exemple
sénateurs rds radical de gauche s'est
inquiétée à rappeler que la fameuse taxe
poids lourds devaient financer de
nombreuses infrastructures en france que
ce soit les tramways que ce soit les bus
les métros des centaines infrastructure
aujourd'hui en danger en effet plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros manquent à
l'agent on se charger de se financer ses
infrastructures là dessus le secrétaire
d'état alain vidalis a cherché à
rassurer le sénateur rappelant tout
d'abord qu'une partie des financements
de cette agence sont pérennes ceux qui
proviennent par exemple et bien des
autoroutes ou encore des amendes des
radars et que la perte de l'écotaxe a
pour l'instant été compensée par la
hausse de prix du gasoil donc encore
quelques années de répit pour cette
infrastructure
l'écologiste ronan dantec s'est lui
aussi inquiété de ce manque à gagner qui
vient de cette perte de l'écotaxe autre
sujet d'inquiétude la manière dont les
régions vont se saisir de la
coordination des transports c'est ce qui
est prévu par le projet de loi sur la
réforme territoriale le deuxième volet
de ce projet de loi d'autant que
certains financements qui étaient déjà
présents dans le projet de loi de
finances et bien ont été stoppés par le
gouvernement là dessus alain vidalis a
renvoyé le sujet enfin le projet de loi
un autre qui sera examinée et bien à
partir du mois de décembre au sénat
enfin notons la question de philippe
dallier le sénateur ump qui lui s'est
penché réellement sur l'île de france
l'a demandé comment allait être financé
baer d'une part le projet du grand paris
express mais aussi et d'un l'extension
la modernisation de l'actuel réseau
francilien l'élu demande une véritable
réunion de l'état de la région et de la
société du grand paris là dessus il n'a
pas du tout été rassuré par la réponse
du ministre voilà donc pour cette séance
de questions cribles thématiques
consacrés au financement des transports
collectifs en france à 16 heures ne
manquez pas notre documentaire le très
sous tension consacré aux sénatoriales
dans les bouches du rhône du rhône
pardon réalisé par notre journaliste
sandra sortira et je me retrouve à 18h
pour l'audition de jean tirole le prix
nobel d'économie a été entendu hier par
les sénateurs de la commission des
affaires économiques très bonne fin de
journée sur les chaînes parlementaires